office of Inspector General
contacted a prosecutor at the Department
of Justice
it informed him that the White House had
notified the archives that documents
bearing classification markings were
identified at the office of attend Biden
Center for diplomacy and Global
engagement
located in Washington DC
that office was not authorized for
storage or classified at documents
the prosecutor was also advised that
those documents had been secured in an
archives facility
on November 9th the FBI commenced an
assessment consistent with standard
protocols to understand whether
classified information had been
mishandled in violation of federal law
on November 14th pursuant to section
600.2 B of the special counsel
regulations I assigned U.S attorney
lausch to conduct an initial
investigation
to inform my decision whether to appoint
a special counsel
Mr lausch has served as U.S attorney in
Chicago since 2017. before that he spent
more than a decade as an assistant U.S
attorney in that same office
I selected him to conduct the initial
investigation because I was confident
his experience would ensure that it
would be done professionally and
expeditiously
on December 20th President Biden's
personal counsel informed Mr lauch that
additional documents fairing
classification markings were identified
in the garage of the president's private
residents in Wilmington Delaware
President Biden's Council inform Mr Loft
that those documents were among other
records from the period of the
president's Service as vice president
the FBI went to the location and secured
those documents
on January 5th 2023. Mr lausch briefed
me on the results of his initial
investigation advised me that further
investigation by a special counsel was
warranted
based on Mr lausch's initial
investigation I concluded that under the
special counsel regulations he was in
the public interest to appoint a special
counsel
in the days since while Mr lausch
continued the investigation
Department identified Mr Herr for
appointment as special counselor
this morning President Biden's personal
Council called Mr love and stated that
an additional document during
classification markings was identified
at the president's personal residence in
Wilmington Delaware
when I first contacted Mr lausch about
this matter he said he could lead the
initial investigation but would be
unable to accept any longer term
assignment because he would be leaving
the department in early 2023 for the
private sector
the U.S attorney lausch and his team of
prosecutors and agents have conducted
this initial investigation with
professionalism and speed
I am grateful to them
earlier today I saw I signed an order
appointing Robert Herr a special counsel
for the matter I just described
the document authorizes him to
investigate whether any person or entity
violated the law in connection with this
matter
special counsel will not be subject to
the day-to-day supervision of any
official of the department but he must
comply with the regulations the
procedures and policies
Mr Herr has a long and distinguished
career as a prosecutor in 2003 he joined
the Department's Criminal Division where
he worked on counter-terrorism corporate
fraud and appellate matters
from 2007 until 2014. Mr Herr served as
an assistant U.S attorney for the
District of Maryland where he prosecuted
matters ranging from violent crime to
financial crime
in 2017 Mr hurry joined the Department
as the principal associate Deputy
Attorney General
in 2018 he was nominated and confirmed
to serve as a U.S attorney for the
District of Maryland
as U.S attorney he supervised some of
the Department's more important National
Security public corruption and other
high-profile matters
I will ensure that Mr Herr receives all
the resources he needs to conduct his
work
as I have said before
I strongly believe that the normal
processes of this department can handle
all investigations with integrity
but under the regulations the
extraordinary circumstances here require
the appointment of a special counsel for
this matter
disappointment underscores for the
public the Department's commitment to
both Independence and accountability and
particularly sensitive matters and to
making decisions indisputably guided
only by the facts and the law
I am confident that Mr herb will carry
out his responsibility in an even-handed
and Urgent Manner and in accordance with
the highest traditions of this
department
thank you all have you ever spoken to
the president about this investigation
sir
okay
everybody
that's what's up
remedy